neues aus england da hieß es bis letzten
freitag noch gibt den insel affen zucker
great britain home aufseher übergewicht
aber jetzt aber jetzt haben die eine
steuer auf getränke mit zuckerzusatz
eingeführt es mutig fish n chips kann
der menschliche körper ohne kohle
eigentlich gar nichts zu ersetzen
die leute donner war eine klassische
vertreterin dieser immer größeren schar
an fettleibigen aber sonst werd ich habe
bis zu 30 dosen cola am tag getrunken
und das über 20 jahre 30 dosen am tag da
misst der arzt nicht mehr den zucker im
blut seines blut im zucker ich meine
klar da sind wir uns einig erwachsene
menschen sollen doch selber entscheiden
wie sie sich umbringen aber es geht ja
auch um kinder und jugendliche
ja hat denn zucker
zucker ist laut aktueller forschung viel
gefährlicher als gedacht sagt unter
anderem die whu wegen der neuen steuer
hat jedenfalls coca cola in seiner
orangen blogger den zuckergehalt in
england auf 4,6 gramm pro 100 milliliter
runtergefahren in deutschland sind es
9,1
hier haben wir die engländer klar
geschlagen deutschland weiß ich habe
ihnen das klar ist deutschland hat sogar
den weltweit dritthöchsten konsum an
zucker gesüßten getränken 84 liter pro
kopf und jahr
und sie müssen wissen zucker lähmung ist
quasi doppelt gefährlich weil sie nicht
satt macht das sind leere kalorien
müssen wir nicht zumindest auch mal über
seine steuern nachdenken wenn man eine
zuckersteuer erhebt auf ein produkt ist
damit noch nicht gewährleistet dass die
gesamt kalorienzahl die aufnahme dadurch
dann so reduziert ist dass wir das thema
viel ernährung in den griff bekommen
gesamt kalorien wir werden mal gesamt
kalorienaufnahme wo habe ich das schon
mal fast wortgleich gelesen ach ja in
der lobby broschüre der wirtschaftlichen
vereinigung zucker ev
es gibt einen lolli extra für julian
selbst wenn man gegen eine nanny staat
ist und ich bin auch gegen einen der
niestadt unsere kinder sollten wir schon
schützen zucker macht süchtig das ist
fakt meine damen und herren
ja das ist wie eine droge deswegen
verkaufen ja die dealer also zum
beispiel alete kekse für kleinkinder ab
dem achten monat mit 25 zucker es gibt
kaum kindernahrung in der nicht
zusätzlicher zucker steckt kinder haben
so verständlich einen vorgefertigten
geschmack das ist ja klar wenn sie wenn
sie muttermilch trinken wenn die kinder
muttermilch trinken da ist sehr viel
zucker drin ganz genau
ja ja muttermilch ist der feind
brandgefährlich gibt es aber jetzt auch
in light und zero zum glück zum glück
[Applaus]